Một thằng sau, phòng cảnh sát đều tra về tham nhúng.
Kinh tế, mô lộ vào môi trường công an tỉnh bình dương cùng lội quản lý thiệt trường số 2 tiến hành kiểm tra tại khó đông lạnh cho推 thu công tý trách nhiệm hiếu hạn đầu tư khó vận biên năng tại khu phổ vấn trái.
Phương lai thiệu, thành phố thuận An.
Lực lượng chức năng đã phát hiện khoảng 1 mổ phẩy 2 tấn thực phẩm đông lạnh nghi vấn vi phạm về sinh An vàn thực phẩm.
Tại thời điểm kiểm tra công tý đang vẫn hành 2 mổ công tinh nơi lại trong đó 2 công tinh nơi chưa nhiều sần phẩm đông lạnh không gió nhấn hiệu học xuất sử,
vô m cấp vấn của thiệt là, cổ, ra, chân, đầu, thiệt theo, bà dọt, thiệt vai, ước vị, xúc sích đã trị biến.
Đăng chú ý, toàn bộ thực phẩm trên điều hết hạn sự dụng không còn hoa đơn, chứng tư trứng mình của nấu khu pháp.
Mặc dù biết sần phẩm đã hết hạn, nhưng chủ hàng vẫn tiếp tục bán ra thì chường cho các cơ sở trị biến nhà hàng,
quan ăn và công tý triếp biến xuất ăn công nghiệp tại định dương và thành phố chiming với mục đích chục lời.
Hẹn số hàng trên đã được nghiêm phong, tạm giữ để sử lý theo quy định pháp lật.